yo what's up this is Doc winter from
iheartmedia check me out on the bootleg
Kev show
the plan all right man bootleg cab
podcast special guest in here
Mr doc winner is here what's up so DOC
for people who don't know yeah what's
your title I'm the president of hip-hop
and R B programming strategy for I heart
and program director of real 92.3 issue
Braille 92.3 yeah
click up on the mic a little bit a
little bit on the mic we gotta start
over are we good no you're good you're
good um so
uh
uh big title you've made plenty of uh of
like the source power 30 list and you've
I mean you're here a very very important
guy in the music industry I gotta thank
you because you've given me opportunity
after opportunity yeah
um well we launched real
um I got a bunch of audition tapes yeah
to this day yours was still the best
yeah that was like late 2014 I might
have sent that I was in Tampa yeah yeah
2015. and whack 100 called me out of
dinner with you and was like I'm with
Doc winner right now tell them about you
I was like
would you say
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and so at that
point in time I called a bunch of
rappers and I was like I need you guys
all to do a drop that says bring bootleg
head to La yeah that was good man and it
worked but I was under contract but it
ended up working out anyway
so um that's some real [__] though when
you think your man's gonna let you out
your contract
I know when I asked I tried to do it the
right way I was like guys it's my dream
job please and I think it all worked out
you know for the best timing was right
for sure
um for like you would originally went to
school for computers right
computer programming what city are you
originally from Doctor originally from
Brooklyn so you're a New York guy and
then you know Queens play ball went to
college in Connecticut
um was a computer programmer uh my homie
worked at the college radio station I
sit up with him sometimes and then uh
when um one spring break he asked me to
fill in for him and you know the
Assumption was always are you from New
York so you can mix you know I was a
Catholic school basketball player but I
was I was [__] with the radio loved
radio loved Frankie Crocker BLS all that
New York [__] yeah and so when I sat in
for that day I prepped my show
I cracked the mic and I don't know if
you had that experience but when I
cracked that mic the first time I was
like wow yeah this is crazy and um it
was a College radio station that it was
one of those towns where the where the
commercial station was on during the
daytime but the college station was on
at night so some people did both and um
this this chick named Jackie Allen never
forget her her brother worked actually
at KISS FM in New York at the time and
she's like yo like I'll know who you are
but you should do this
so so you went from the college did you
did you finish getting your degree yeah
it was a computer I started working as a
computer programmer and worked at the
college station at the same time and
then I got a job at a commercial station
what was your first commercial gig it
was uh new 98 FM in Willimantic
Connecticut wow yeah it was it was what
market number is that dude I have no
idea all I know is I I would I was a
computer programmer so I was I was
making a little money and so
you know I think I started up part-time
then I went to full time and um like it
it was tight then man so I I remember
one day going in with my um my dinner
before I was about to go on air put my
Big Mac down
went to the bathroom and washed my hands
came back somebody had taken a bite out
of my [__] yeah because Jesus it was
tight like tight like that it was tight
what were you do you remember what you
were making an hour
I was
I think I was making 20 something as a
computer programmer so great money back
I'm making more than the program
director at the radio station which was
which was an issue of course it's
actually an interesting story like he
basically hired me to fill in overnights
a weekend that he was going to be gone
back then it was no you know you had to
have somebody in the building right at
all times and um I'm thinking I'm
auditioning he's in another part of the
country but his wife was listening and
she was like yo like you need to hire
this dude she she ended up telling me
the story like a couple years later
crazy he wasn't even listening to you
and I told him like yo you need to hire
that dude so
um but it might have been it might have
been five bucks an hour at the time so
you go from doing that what would you
say was your first like
significant break that made you kind of
be like I can
leave the programming job aside and
really pursue the radio thing so from uh
new 98 in Willimantic I went to wnhc in
New Haven which was like a am
a 24-hour radio station and I was doing
our overnight sales working for Jazzy
Jordan I was doing part-time and
um my boy uh Bobby uh was doing mornings
he was going on vacation and she asked
me to fill in I was actually getting
ready to go on vacation one of those
things that radio people do and she you
know sometimes it takes a minute for the
things to kick in right and I was like I
need to cancel this vacation and do
mornings so I've done that before I
canceled my vacation I did mornings for
a week and then um
at the end of the week Friday she called
me in the office and she was like yo how
would you like to do it full time I was
like yo Bobby's my guy that's my homie
yeah he's like yeah that's business you
want it or not and I was like wow
wow seriously and um I was able to I was
able to talk to him before things went
down let him know like No Malice and
later on once I got this position I was
able to give him
an opportunity but so I ended up started
doing mornings there worked there for a
while then I I wanted to see what it was
going to be like to work at top 40 radio
because you know it was a different
thing yeah
um black radio locally versus top 40
radio
um so I went like the top 40 for about a
year that's how I got into the company I
was the black guy in the top 40 station
what shift was I doing that's overnights
[Laughter]
overnights and and having the the white
girls roll up on you at the promotion is
like mad when they find out 2G black it
was it was actually pretty hilarious
so that's when I end up
making the trend you know like I I gotta
let go you know my parents are Jamaican
that was for clear water or clear clear
Channel cheeses at the time at the time
it was
um it was J core okay it was actually
Noble broadcast group and then Jay core
bought us then we later on became Clear
Channel but you know my parents were lit
man they're like yo we went to school to
be a computer programmer like what are
you doing they weren't too happy oh not
at all like you know Jamaicans like we
don't do like we're like everybody in my
family I got doctors lawyers judges like
you know our our family like they had a
plan we came over here you get educated
you get a job and so that was contrary
to the plan but you know like I told my
pops like yo Dad I think I can be really
good at this yeah and um so um once I
got to this job 10 years later he was
good yeah he was good he was good with
it after that but initially he was a
little tight about it yeah
um you've been a part of like obviously
some pretty historical stuff in radio
um
you pretty much you did so I mean you
signed on real 92 3 in La which was a
very crazy thing to do at the time
because there is a Heritage station here
that
nobody would ever really think to [__]
with yep
um also you were very instrumental in uh
The Breakfast Club right a launched a
launch Power 105.1 so you launched power
105. at the time when you launched it it
was Ed Lover in the morning yep Ed and
uh Dr Dre the other Dr Dre yep the other
one and then um we went through a couple
of iterations of morning shows um I
think we uh Tigger was doing warnings at
one time then we had uh I think before
that it might have been uh star and book
Wild yeah how was that what were those
calls like
you know I tell everybody all the time
man like like he and I had a great
relationship man I like there was never
any malice between us he gave people a
hard time but I mean like me and him
were good man yeah like I remember he
and I having a conversation one time
about how many times he was gonna use
the n-word on his show because at this
time he was doing it like every two
seconds you say like hey you got five
percent no we I I vaguely remember the
conversation but I remember him
negotiating it down to 25. 25 times a
show 25 times uh an hour an hour show it
was it was Sun it was which is kind of
crazy because technically you couldn't
say it on the radio yeah technically you
can but it wasn't an Advertiser friendly
term for sure you might imagine and so I
remember bad for business to use it I
remember we he and I settled on that and
then um you know it progressively got
went back up to 40 and then you know
then those things
um ended crazy I don't ever want to take
credit for The Breakfast Club higher
because it was actually Cadillac Jack I
remember him calling me and telling me I
knew who Charlemagne was I knew who Envy
was because of what happened with star
um and I was aware who Angela was and at
the time the show started was the very
beginning of PPM
um early PPM early PPM measurement there
were a lot of misconceptions about PPM
measurement and the biggest problem was
that you should know if a show is a hit
within weeks also for people who don't
know what PPM is it's the it's a meter
that tells radio stations their ratings
exactly it's an imperfect system and
before that it used to be a diary so you
would get a diary correct you would
write down what you thought you listened
to versus what you actually listened to
much easier way to program it absolutely
much easier way so um so the show
started
um you know remember Cadillac and I
talking about it I thought it was a
great idea
um but it didn't hit as quickly as
um people thought and we had done
something similar in Chicago with a
Morning Show and I remember that morning
show took a minute so
um after a few months when it didn't hit
I was called in for me in New York and
there was actually a thought of maybe
doing something different and um I
remember after a few months after a few
months okay because that was the
misconception at the time but I but
there was a chemistry between the three
that was like nothing I'd ever seen
right and um I remember being in a room
with them just kind of like you know
just we just talking and just like man
like if we could have a if this gets on
the radio and we give it time and we
promote it it's gonna be crazy I had no
idea would be what it became but yeah I
know you fielded calls for stuff I've
said before at least I know AOS about
artists have you ever had to deal with
blowback for like early Charlemagne
stuff where they're like yo
and I know you know before real you were
you obviously based in Jacksonville but
like you're at the I feel like you're
kind of the face of like yeah
who the industry talks to when it comes
to I heart [__] on the hip-hop side you
are that literally so was there ever any
like always always
um especially at the very early
different iterations of Charlemagne I
think early on he was he was wrong
and so um I get those complaints
obviously back in the day before uh
Charlemagne star was
was routine man like NAACP would want me
to come I'm like I'm not coming
like nah man like like if you took the
show locally I would always tell them
like you you took the show you know what
you got like you got to handle it like
I'm not flying across the country and
meeting with the you know United Negro
College Fund NAACP every city because
every city that that was Affiliated
affiliated with the show because they
were hot you know um so but um but yeah
I mean they were there were there were
complaints it's part of the culture I
just I'm just wondering if like you know
you look at your phone and like it says
Diddy's calling right and then Diddy's
like yo yo doc
this is [__] by the way that's just
the name yeah yeah I mean it still
happens to this day yeah I mean I think
um some people think that that's what we
do we we set them up for the um you know
to get the clip on on social media which
I don't think you guys intentionally do
I think it just happens sometimes but
yeah
but yeah get them a lot do you feel like
because I do I I I don't think um
artists at least even five ten years
back
appreciate the radio promo run like they
used to you know what I mean like I feel
like a lot of these younger guys didn't
necessarily break on radio and or
understand the importance of radio or do
you notice that in terms of like certain
artists maybe not wanting to do
you know come to the station or do a
radio run or do like a promo show [__]
like that not a lot but some yeah
um again just not well educated I think
they've fallen into the fantasy of
streaming which you know I don't
necessarily buy it buy it all that it's
legitimate I I think if you want to be a
household name though you want to be on
the radio yeah I wish everybody I say
look you have a career you could be big
you could but if you win a number one
record
especially markets like La where people
are always in the car right like you
know and
you know people always talk about you
know radios ability to survive man like
the best talent in the world is on the
radio like you know you could you could
you could put on a playlist but I'd
rather hear you and James talk about
something and then play my favorite
record or you and big right or The
Breakfast Club or we just have a lot of
great talent in our stable and you know
I think they're they're gonna take us
into the next that's what I was gonna
say in terms of like obviously radio as
an industry is like shrinking in terms
of like the amount of bodies that are
around like yeah like even like on the
record side you know people are getting
let go it's it just it feels like more
and more the if you think I like the UK
and they have BBC do you feel like
eventually they'll be like some I don't
think they'll ever be like a BBC type
situation in the US I just think there's
too many companies involved yeah but you
feel like eventually they'll they'll be
something similar where it's like this
is the morning show for the US this is
the you know what I mean like do you
feel like it's gonna get there or or no
I don't think so because I think
I I think big makes sense for LA right I
think didn't make sense for New York he
was on 97 for a little bit no yeah I
probably never told him this story but I
remember my boss calling me and saying
hey should should we do this and and I'd
met big loved him and I think you know
growing up in New York City I was like
no it's a different vibe 100 there's
cities there's cities that are like that
yeah like he's one of the funniest most
talented people I've ever met for sure
and and I mean that sincerely but New
York is just a different animal it is
and New Yorkers are they want to hear
New Yorkers on the radio they want to
know you're there they want to know yeah
and you got to have a little you know it
could be a little nasty at times you
know and that's their expectation and
they deserve to get what it is that they
want you know just like you should in
Atlanta you should in DC what are some
of those other cities that you're like
this this you know this kind of needs
yeah Memphis is different Memphis is
dead New Orleans is different yeah
Jacksonville Duval is different Tampa
was like was like that I remember being
in Tampa and being like I can't imagine
like even the morning show who's on the
top 40 station was I heart station
what's the top 40 guy who was over there
forever
of uh Bubba no no no no the top the I
Heart top 40 guys based in DC but he
streamed in Tampa
Kane oh Kane yeah yeah
um so you can talk about how can you
talk about Tampa radio not talk about
the Love Sponge
yo shout out to him so shout out to him
he actually worked for me for about
a month What station was it when I got
to Jacksonville okay he was on Sunday
nights oh Wild guy wild show dude like I
one of my favorite stories to tell about
radio involved him so he was on when I
got to Jacksonville I only I was only
programming wsol initially that's the
urban AC and my boy Paco Lopez was
programming uh the beat I remember one
of our first meetings with our boss at
the time was Kevin Matheny Kevin was the
power not the power but Kevin was Howard
Stern's boss if you ever saw the movie
wnbc teaching them how yeah pig pig
vomiting yeah right so Kevin was my
first boss when I got to Jacksonville
and
um
so Paco and Kevin and I are having our
first staff meeting when I get to
Jacksonville and so Paco uh is
complaining about Bubba you know
following directions doing whatever and
you know I mean that was Bubba and so I
remember uh we're in it we're in the
room and Kevin got rested so like you
know
I remember telling to go get telling
Paco to go get
um Bubba's
phone number and he threw some he threw
something at him told him you know get
out and go get his number and I was like
oh [__] right so I remember I was
waiting for Paco to come I was like man
Kev like dude um did I ever tell you I'm
from Brooklyn right and he's like yeah I
was like yeah man because honestly like
that pen that [__] don't fly it's coming
right back at you right and I remember
he just turned right round so now I'm
not trying to be disrespectful I'm just
wired differently yeah like like that's
not gonna work for me I remember him
looking at me turning bright red and we
were good after that never ever ever
but you know it was like it was my first
time really like seeing that kind of
management style and it's like Old
School radio [__] yeah I was like okay
yeah that's just the second worked for
me though I just heard like back in the
day man like I would always like guys
like uh would I wouldn't even say their
names but just I heard like way way back
probably even
Rock Radio Days like used to be able to
like get your record on if you dropped
off like a eight ball of cocaine you're
like some of these like rock PDS in the
70s you know yo man it was it was a
different it was a different environment
because
um when I got to when I later became the
PD of jbtn Sol gotta remember Sol's on
the urban adult panel and jbt at the
time was on the rhythmic panel not the
urban panel
yo what up it's bootleg cab we got to
stop the interview to tell you about our
folks at my bookie that's right so many
ways you can gamble with my bookie right
now man of course you got NBA playoffs
Western Conference Finals Eastern
Conference Finals they're set I love
Celtics versus Lakers in the finals all
right you can sign up at mybookie.ag
right now using that promo code bootleg
and get a very generous first deposit
bonus that's right and they just got the
craziest like revamp of the online
casino it's like a Las Vegas experience
if you play cards Blackjack roulette uh
you shoot dice whatever it is they have
like live dealers handling it for you
wherever you're at you could be at the
airport and be playing [__] roulette
on your phone it's amazing mybookie.ag
sign up with that promo code bootleg
right now you could've been on Sports
you could do slots you could do
Blackjack uh craps whatever you're into
mybookie.ag promo code bootleg for that
first deposit bonus and it is a generous
one also gotta give a shout out to our
family at King Palms shout out to King
Palm man if you only know about King
Palms they're our new sponsor on the
bootleg kept podcast and they got such a
great product the best thing about King
Palms is it's all organic man no tobacco
in these wraps they're straight Leafs
and the best thing uh about them is they
got this product
their flavor terpene tips all right you
stuff them with your with your product
do we got one here oh we do got one here
we got one right here we got one right
here all right
you stuff this with your uh premium
cannabis from Hardy in Las Vegas
all right you smoke up pinch that tip
you're gonna get a burst of flavor yeah
this is the energy drink flavor we got
Peach pineapple we got watermelon wave
also don't forget the goddamn
blue grapes you know what I mean and
also this is a tobacco-free wrap it's
totally organic it's literally a leaf
let me show you what I mean
that is just a big ass Leaf guys all
right so what you could do is go to
kingpom.com weeds flying everywhere
kingpom.com promo code bootleg and uh
you can get 50 off of whatever you order
at kingpom.com and don't forget to check
them out because they're everywhere your
local smoke shop your local liquor store
7-Eleven smoke the King Palm all right
it's organic it ain't like all that
other [__] y'all be [__] stuffing
in your lungs man all right shout out to
kingpom kingpom.com promo code bootleg
right now and it's actually promo code
bootleg Kev promo code bootleg Kev not
bootleg bootleg cab kingpom.com half off
everything let's get back to the
interview it's on the urban panel of
course yes and jbt is on the rhythmic
panel so I I'd come from St Louis at
kmjm so I knew every you know all the
urban people so
now I have this whole slew of people
that I don't know most of whom are white
and you talking about the record reps
yeah and it's a totally different vibe
right like I I was a member of Hitman
Hayes who's in um he's in San Diego San
Diego now was my music director at the
time I remember walking to his office
one time to ask him and he's on speaker
and some dude is just like yelling at
him like oh you [__]
yeah and I was like so I was like dude
that's like yo who who is that it was
it's a record guy oh I said and he's
talking to you like that he said yeah I
was like hang up on them
you got it yeah I just hung up on him I
was like man like I don't ever want to
hear you letting somebody talk to you
like that again I'll fire you you know
what I'm saying and uh you know our
relationship was great at that moment he
still works in the company he was great
but it was just so different to see how
you know the Reps were different and you
know it was great for me because I had
an opportunity to meet all of those
people and I've had relation
long-standing relationships with people
on both sides of the equation but yeah
even me like when I got hired it real
technically yeah it was the first urban
thing ever worked so obviously worked at
tons of hip-hop stations but there's
hip-hop stations on the Rhythm path yeah
so coming to Rio yeah I'm beating all
these record reps you know I had before
I had never had relationships like I
like Dwight or you know guys exactly
there's like a whole new group of guys
and we should probably explain the whole
idea between rhythmic and urban correct
so for people who don't know Hot 97 is a
hip-hop station but it's on the Rhythm
panel yeah so there's a rhythmic chart
yep and there's uh I believe around 60
stations that report to it probably give
or take right yeah so Power 106 in La
that we're smoking in the ratings uh Hot
97 in New York those are hip-hop
stations that are on the rhythmic panel
got it on the urban panel there's a ton
of stations on the urban panel a lot
more stations right
um
typically but there's a story behind
that too yeah what is that story story
behind that is let's just keep it real
rhythmic stations play predominantly
black people hip-hop 100 most of the
jocks are white most program directors
are white and then out of touch and
weird and cringiest I'm not trying I'm
just I'm trying to just no you're just
the facts listen and so then on the
urban panel
directors of black and on the record
side most of those people are people of
color so here I am I started overseeing
the urbans for the company in 2000 and
around 2003 was the first time we
decided to launch power in New York and
working with Steve Smith Tom Pullman
who's still on us that's crazy Steve
Smith helped launch that station yeah
and he launched hot 97. that was my God
rip God bless the soul yeah and so then
the conversation comes up and they're
like okay so yeah we're gonna put it on
the uh rhythmic panel like oh no no no
no no no no
not me yeah I'm the head of urban yeah
black to New York City it's my city I'm
not putting a hip-hop station on and
putting it on the Ripley panel and they
just it the conversation was literally
about two seconds and that's one of the
things about I loved about Tom to this
day at the time you're like you're right
it should be and so then fast forward 15
years later we get ready to launch real
same thing
two second conversation nope I don't do
that like so what they wanted you to run
it at on the Rhythm panel yeah oh wow
but that that's jobs man you know we
create jobs when we put an urban on it
no for sure and power is still in urban
we created jobs when we put
um real on in La same thing in Houston
with the beat same thing in Miami with
the beat same thing
um but one of those things I know for me
personally was important for me to do
and it was important that our company
supported us because I was like like
that's crazy like why would why would we
do that yeah it doesn't make any sense
and I always didn't understand the
this is like kind of getting into some
inside baseball but I never really
understood
the lack of Urban's
on the west coast in general like I
think of a station like KMEL right KML
it's an urban station but it's not it's
on the Rhythm panel yeah you know but
it's like that's a
it's like is that the I think that might
be the first hip-hop station
Cameo on the west coast I think it was
the first
but yeah it's some real radio nerd [__]
but it's definitely like if you're an
artist right and like maybe you are
because a lot of up-and-coming artists
watch the podcast like you're you've got
to kind of make a decision if you have a
record and you have a budget which chart
you're going to chase right yeah so it's
like I want to go to the rhythmic side
I'm going to go on the urban side I'm
going to go on the top 40 side and then
you make a decision from there yeah it's
it's actually crazy because when if you
looked at our playlist for real in La we
have rhythmic sensibilities for sure
where's Bad Bunny getting played Steve
Lacy you know for sure and it's a
function of our audience 100 you know
our audience here is predominantly
Latino with some African-Americans and
you know you go to Atlanta it's totally
different you go to La I mean you go to
New York it's totally different and you
know usually the playlist is a function
of the diet that that audience was fed
upon we're here in here in La the diet
was more rhythmic right and so as you
put a station on here in La gradually
like when I launched it we launched it
like it was a urban station but
gradually it's begun to take on it's
like its own thing yeah its own thing
because of the feedback from the audio I
was gonna say like
obviously you've been a part of
launching two two of the I mean Market
one and two talking about Power 105.1
real 92.3 each against the biggest
Heritage hip-hop stations in the country
yeah
it I mean what were some of the bumps
and bruises for each City because
obviously it took you a few morning
shows to land on The Breakfast Club yeah
it helps if you're in LA and you launch
with big boy absolutely
um what were some of the bumps and
bruises where you kind of had to like
because again like there's no rules for
each City you got to kind of like learn
on the Fly I'm sure for each station
that you that you launched because
you've launched so many power with power
was different in that you know I was
again I I was like two three years into
the job but I mean my team respected me
but I also was the only black person and
the only New Yorker right that was
involved in the equation so sometimes
you just gotta you gotta muscle your way
in and like now we're gonna do it this
way brand new that way because we're all
type A personalities
um and then once we launched
um my mindset was I was going to bring
different people in from different radio
stations that I oversaw to put them on
the air hindsight that was a mistake
okay I think
it's got to be people from that City
yeah to make it work because it's it's a
lot or at least predominantly
predominantly absolutely it's a local
radio station so it should be people who
live and breathe and eat and sound like
that city
um and I think I made a mistake then and
that's not casting [__] on anybody there
right but I think in the best interest
of the radio station and I think I
learned that here in La like you you
know people got to be from here they got
to be able to talk and sound and you
know and and speak the language of the
city
um launching with big was obviously a
it's like a cheat code huge Advantage
for us we wouldn't have done it if we
didn't so yeah I think that people don't
understand there would not be a real
92.3 if I heart hadn't have napped big
boy it wouldn't have been worth going
against him no I didn't think we were
going to do it honestly I remember when
we first when Tom first reached out and
said hey you know I think this could be
the play and this is like in 2014 I
think I had met big in maybe 2008 when
we were considering uh syndication with
him and I come out to LA and one of the
things I knew about him is he was
incredibly loyal super loyal guy great
incredibly loyal I'm like unless they
really really messed up he's not leaving
and
um I never forget I was in it was late
December
might have been the first week or two in
January 2015 I'm in New York in a
meeting with 50 Cent get a text on my
phone
like yo we're ready to go
got it done I gotta get on the phone I
gotta negotiate my new contract with my
boss did that in like five minutes and
then because at that point in time
you're realizing you're moving to La
yeah have to let my lady know by the way
um I think we're gonna be moving to La
she's like let's go you know and uh and
excuse myself in that meeting with 50
I'm like yo I got to get on a plane and
go to LA tomorrow go find a place to
live and get ready to launch a radio
station then my next call was the AO who
I had just made the PD in Miami yeah hey
I know you really really like Miami oh
he really likes Miami yeah
it's legendary
he'll kill you um I was like hey man
what we uh why don't you come with me to
La let's do this and he was like yo
let's go yeah yeah that's my God man no
it's crazy because
um
like you said like it was like a very
last from what I understand the whole
well first of all there was like a
lawsuit right with involving big leaving
right yeah so I remember you telling me
like hey man
we're in the middle of this legal ship
with big boy
so if you're if you gotta you gotta get
out of your deal they have to let you
out we can't like yeah I wasn't I wasn't
but because I was like dude I could just
quit and then pop up in that light
you're like no not this he's like this
big [__] wasn't happening maybe but and
big wasn't big wasn't the only one there
were there were a couple people that I
had
um I had interviewed who I wanted to
bring on a team who were working in
Television right and they were the
mindset oh yeah I could do a different
medium I could do both right I'd be like
no you got to get approval like no no
they're good I already spoken to him
about it and just like you when they
went hell no nah not doing it and they
were they were blown away and I'm like
there's nothing we can do about it but
yeah I know for me moving forward it was
never again because in some instances
and I know in in one deal in particular
I actually said okay let's put the deal
in front of you and then you can take it
to your boss as opposed to you getting
permission first and the boss said no
yeah I had a meeting with uh some
redneck guy from Beasley and Orlando
love Orlando because he he was like I'm
I told him yes yeah he's like we got to
go sit with I think it I forget the you
know those beasleys are from like
Augusta Georgia or some [__] yeah and
the guy was like you know you're gonna
regret this I gotta say you're number
one right now yeah can't just let you go
tie to our heart poaching our talent
yeah yeah so it didn't work out but
um it's crazy doc because you're in a
position where
you can really press the button on
changing someone's trajectory of their
career yeah and I know you don't take
that lightly
um I also know that artists are very
emotional
they're very emotional when it comes to
their art yeah and I've heard you
just tell people this ain't it this is
not a I remember we had a random I don't
know if fetty WAP was there somebody
from 300 was there when fetty WAP kept
just putting up Duds and I remember
shout out to fetty WAP he just got
sentenced to six years in prison free
fetty white
um but I've seen you like just you're a
very blunt guy when it comes to telling
people about their records like how hard
is it to be like I'm I know I don't want
to spill any names or anything but you
had situations where artists have gotten
really emotional with you yeah top tier
biggest artists in the world yeah
pulled out of certain situations for I
heart over just dumb [__] but like for
you how do you like
I guess tiptoe that line where you're
you're you know you could be friendly
with somebody you could look out for
somebody but you know you're not gonna
just
yo your record's getting added on all
these I heart stations just because you
you're so and so it's it's honestly sad
in some respects because it is the
nature of our format there are formats
like country where like they love their
people from 18 to to 75 and they're
gonna play the record and country
artists
absolutely but it's a function of that
right it just happens not to be true
about our format our format is 18 to 34
targeted and
when you turn 35 you go someplace you
know you leave and then that 17 year old
turns 18 and they come in and they have
specific taste interest and
sometimes you'll get it you know you'll
get a legacy artist who's done the damn
thing for 25 years and one day it's over
and you have to tell them
and they don't appreciate it because
they feel like yo like
and I get it I I totally get it it's
just it's just innate and every once in
a while they'll they'll put one in that
will work but it's it's not it's it's
the exception it's the exception
everyone's always one hit away yep
especially with tick tock do you have
like a blacklist of artists who've just
it's like [__] you like like you've done
a a b and c to me the bridge is burnt
oh
first of all I'm not saying you're gonna
tell me who's on the list but is there a
list first of all I I I don't really
have that because I'm I don't put that
out I have really good relationships
I've had
three really bad experiences
three three that's really bad in 35
years I've had three wow
um one is an artist who will remain
nameless but
he was at that particular part of his
career I was in New York at a party
having a conversation and a drink with a
very nice young lady and label came over
and said hey so-and-so so-and-so wants
to say what's up to you so
I get up I walk over to where where
they're standing and I'm immediately
taken back because of the stature of the
individual it was really really really
really really really short and I didn't
expect I knew but I didn't know you know
right and you know there were some heels
that were really and I was like Wow and
then he just started going in
um there was a another misconception
that there was some national playlist
that I
presided over it and that his music
wasn't on it and he felt like I was the
one and I'm like dude like you're wrong
there is no such list it's just
your time has come and gone like you
know yeah so the kids if it's not a hit
it's not a hit a Marketplace will tell
me if I need to play your [__] yeah
exactly but he was I mean he was living
and you know I I was looking down and
like still like like wow little dude and
his bodyguard was standing um to his
right and his bodyguard was like looking
like he just I'm waiting for you to say
something wrong yeah and if you know me
I just kind of like
all right man have a good night let's
turn around walked away and he used to
deal like like I'm not gonna sit here
and have this conversation with you
because you don't want to have a
conversation like you wanna right you
have a you have a interesting
relationship with Kanye because I
remember listen I remember well no no no
I remember
um because I wanted to ask you about
this there was one of those rants on the
life of Pablo tour when yay was like
floating above the crowd and in one of
the rants I believe he was in Sacramento
or San Francisco he mentioned your name
specifically in one of these like
30-minute Kanye rants in the middle of
his performance like obviously since
then you've you know you've seen Kanye
you know he's obviously I I'm I'm not
talking about since the uh you know the
uh the current situation he's in yeah
but since that specific instance like
what do you when you wake up in the
morning again you're the most
mild-mannered cool dude and you see
Kanye just went on a rant mentions my
name what do you like do you give a [__]
or no it doesn't pay my rent like I
really didn't give a [__] my mom was
excited my family was excited you know I
got hit up around the country about it
but um I mean no I don't even know what
led to that because at that time we we
actually had a really good relationship
and I would go and listen to his album
usually would grab big and go with him
listen to Big Boy and go listen to his
album and so but but maybe I he wasn't
getting the feedback from me at the time
because it things had started to change
uh from him um in the marketplace but I
don't I don't even know what what caused
the the rant but um but yeah I thought I
thought it was funny yeah so how long
has DJ Khaled called you doc Winters
doc Winters to the point where I
actually thought about changing my name
to Doc Winters since everybody calls me
it's almost like everyone used to call
Joe Budden Joe Budden it's like it's
winter I think it's funny actually Kyle
is my God man great guy yeah he's
hilarious
right it's getting hot outside you know
what that means fellas you're about to
go get that dick wet you know what I'm
saying it might as well be really hard
it might as well be as hard as it could
possibly be and with Bluetooth you will
achieve such hardness all right it's
seriously amazing uh and the best part
about Bluetooth is you can find out if
it works don't just take my word for it
they're going to give you a month's
supply for free go to bluetooth.com use
that promo code bootleg get a month
supply for free bluetooth.com promo code
bootleg now it's the same active
ingredient as Viagra and Cialis minus
the awkward doctor appointment you do
not have to go see some old dude and
tell them about your erectile
dysfunction issues in person because
that's a [__] awkward conversation
bruh all you got to do is go to
bluetooth.com right now use the promo
code bootleg they're going to get you
hooked up with a month of supply for
free you just gotta pay five dollars in
shipping no awkward doctor's
appointments same active ingredient as
Viagra fancy Atlas plus they got the
Bluetooth mint it's a chewable it's
great tastes like mint it's also the
same active ingredient as Levitra so
summertime's coming fellas you don't
want to underperform make sure your dick
is rocked up baby all right go to
bluetooth.com use the promo code bootleg
hey man it works what do you want from
me it [__] works everyone should have
a little Bluetooth in case of an
emergency
you might have an emergency you need to
pop a Bluetooth to it it's a chewable
you know what I mean anyway also got a
shout out to our family at Odd Socks
don't forget go to oddstocksofficial.com
promo code bootleg save 20 off man they
got the underwear that they just dropped
uh last year that's amazing so not only
do you get the most comfortable socks in
the world but you can also get the most
comfortable for draws in the world all
the crazy licenses they gotta have baked
socks they just announced their Hasbro
collection which is crazy because that
means you're going to get Monopoly socks
Transformer socks Power Ranger socks so
much [__] going with Odd Socks plus they
got The Odd Socks Basics my favorite
this is why I wear every day I wear the
basics because they're the most
comfortable socks I've ever put on my
[__] feet so experience the most
comfortable socks in the world with me
oddsoxofficial.com promo code bootleg
save 20 off shout out to Odd Socks let's
get back to the interview so
another thing I wanted to talk about doc
because I do feel like we are in like a
new era of just the music industry we
talked about streaming we talked about
Tick Tock like what would be your advice
I always tell artists when they ask me
and you can tell me if I'm wrong or not
but I always tell them to worry about
radio last okay to me it's like the last
Peg of like you know like if you're an
up and I get hit up by guys with 10 000
followers yeah and they're like yo man
from [__] I'm from the city put me on
it on real you know I'm just like don't
worry about me yet like yeah no I think
that's good advice yeah I always say
worry the radio is the last thing to
come worry about
you know developing a following your
fans you know getting your [__] off the
ground put an album out something like
but what would be advice you would give
in terms of like just an up-and-coming
artist and how they should maneuver
around getting on the radio
yeah I think it's no different from back
in the day where I think you have to
create a story for yourself like back in
the day we would say create something
locally
now I would probably say create
something socially you know get yourself
a buzz
um I think you got to work on your art I
think because you never know when it's
time to press play and you got to be
ready to do business and I always ask
people like especially after like you
know the first year so so how was it
like yo shit's a grind like yeah it's
not fun like it's work it's work yeah
it's work you're getting up doing these
morning shows doing these shows and
you're trying to party and then you got
to get up and do shows like it's like
not everybody's built for it you know um
so that's my advice and then also handle
your business yeah um because you may
you may get two albums you may you may
not
um you should have some licensing some
publishing to continue to take care of
your family you may move into a
different aspect of the business but I
think you got to start looking at it
from that perspective because things can
change what about your advice for a a
listen and I tell
anybody who asked me that they want to
get into the radio industry for the most
part
I say I don't know man my time might
have passed like so what if somebody's
watching this and their aspirations are
to do radio it's it's obviously by the
day getting tougher and tougher to crack
because of just the nature of our
business the economics of our business
um what would be your advice to somebody
who wants to get into radio man get
yourself a podcast man
work on your craft
with an opportunity presents itself
um but but honestly man like there's so
few opportunities for really to hone
your Craft
um I think you got to be on the air
frequently to do that podcast gives you
an opportunity to do that but um I mean
Only the Strong are surviving right now
there's some incredibly talented people
like myself who who are out of work and
then there's some incredibly talented
people like yourself who who have um
carve the niche for themselves and now
they're now they're on more than one
radio station right there's a lot of
people outside of radio trying to take
multiple jobs and I get a lot of those
meetings and you know sometimes like
sometimes I gotta kind of like throw it
back at them like you do realize what
you're asking me to do is take 25 30
people's jobs and give it to you right
and they've never ever thought about it
that way yeah like you're expecting yeah
like real people's lives like like
honestly because we really don't have to
unless you know we needed to but you're
asking me basically to take
30 jobs from people and just give it to
you because you know you may or may not
be more talented but it's real you know
and um you know I take that into
consideration it's not something I take
lightly yeah because I feel like the
days of like uh
being on the street team then getting a
weekend shift those days are like slow
it's because I and I talk to a lot of
programmers and they're like yo just the
talent pool is kind of yeah you know
it's it's kind of shrinking and there's
a lot of good people out there's a lot
of good radio people it's not a lot of
great radio people there's not a lot of
great radio people and I think there's a
lot of great if they are great
on you know from three to seven or you
know ten to three or whatever they're
not willing to fully Embrace what it
means in 2023 a radio personality
anymore yeah and that's what I tell
everybody like any of these young jocks
that will reach out to me I'm like you
have to
this is a full like this is not a four
hour a day job oh man you gotta be a
content creator you gotta you know
blogging aside blog you know because I
know that's a big you know if you work
at a radio station one of the most
annoying things so I gotta [__] know
but like you have to be on your social
you have to build you're a brand Builder
man one of the one of the things that I
love about my job and you know I say
this a lot internally I have like three
or four morning shows
on my team right got big I got cruise I
got your show and um we spent a lot of
time early on I did anyway uh explaining
the science
of PPM and how I thought it would be the
best way for you to Garner the the most
ratings or from a technical perspective
how you deliver when you deliver and
stuff like that but in terms of the
content you guys have all handled that
yeah like you guys do your job and you
know no one has to tell me nobody hey
yes it's like nor big nor Cruise yeah I
have to tell you guys go get content 99
of the time I'm finding out this is the
occasion where I'll send you or them a
text about something oh yeah I talked
about that three days ago yeah like damn
like you guys are on it which makes for
great radio but then you have people who
don't have the talent that you guys have
don't have the work ethic that won't
want a job I hear I I sometimes I'll
talk to like you know some of my ogs in
the radio game
and just the way they talk I'm just like
oh this is why this is why you're not
employed yeah man like you know they
wanted me to tick tock and I needed to
post a certain amount of times a day and
I'm like listen man like this is the
world we live in you know like it just
is what it is and that's the craziest
thing man I've had Talent on my team
that have complained about stuff like
that I'd be like man like
I don't get this complaint from Big Boy
so you got a big stand it's difficult
for me to wash down this complaint from
you that you've gotta now obviously he's
put himself in a position where he's got
a team for sure for sure for sure
facilitate some of that stuff but at the
end of the day it gets done
um and at some point in his career he
had to do it on his own as well so it's
difficult for me to
swallow the fact that you got you know
you three four years into this and
you're already complaining about what
you want to do it's kind of crazy was
there ever an artist doc that you almost
convinced to be on the radio
an artist
I did convince Keith Sweat to be on a
radio which he still is so that was you
that's me oh shout out to you there was
a time in my career because you were
doing the St Louis slow jam show the
slow jam show and there was a time in my
career where I wanted to be the slow jam
guy on everybody's station and my boss
at the time Tom Owen said he said okay
that's that's interesting he said you
could be that guy or you could be the
guy that hires that guy which guy do you
want to be I was like I want to be the
guy that hires that guy
and as we began to move into that space
where we were looking for somebody to
take that position I always thought I
thought of Rob Kelly and I thought of
Keith
um Rob was still by the way good
decision
Rob is still
still more relevant um uh at the time
with current music and uh Keith that
actually honestly expressed an interest
that just happened to run into him and
he expressed an interest as I was
getting ready to vacate
um the St Louis job and we were getting
ready to talk about who was going to be
that person and
um it worked out this just worked out
perfectly because he's how long has that
show been happening man that's been he's
been on it almost 20 years man that
shit's crazy yeah and doing well anybody
that you tried to convince but it didn't
maybe just for whatever I've heard some
wild names about like
I mean you know we I've heard some names
not the necessarily you were involved
with but
um I had a comedian one time who I
thought was hilarious that I really
thought could do it and um he was
supposed to meet me in a market I think
was Philadelphia he was supposed to meet
me in Kevin Hart no no
and we were supposed to do we were
supposed to create an audition tape for
him so that I could submit it to uh our
syndication company and talk about it
and uh when the day came he never showed
up
and no showed no showed let's say this
was
let's say this was 2009.
foreign
2019 I'm coming into our station here at
Burbank walking walk right into him do
an interview do the interview with big
and
um didn't remember myself I don't know
if you remember me but you know doc from
I heart you and I talked all the time
about syndication you know you know no
showed me and you never showed he's like
me and I was like yeah and he's like
what's your name again and I was just
like are you serious right now and then
you know we exchanged numbers and then
he hit me up ladies like man I I
apologize if you know that ever happened
so I was doing a lot of wild [__] at
that time I could have just slipped my
mind I was like okay cool well what
about now I was like nah I'm good I'm
like no I'm good I don't think we ought
to go back down that road again I was
gonna say like for you
um you obviously you're friends with a
guy like Nick right Nick ends up doing
mornings for a short period of time
across the street he was also on moving
to New York which I'm sure was against
iHeart at a certain point in time but
yeah
um
like what is it like to compete against
friends
um
I've had blunt conversations with Nick
about you know about radio I think he's
a phenomenal television host and
everything I just and and as an artist
as well as an artist I've had
conversation with him too
um it's business man you know because
I'm sure throughout your career that's
happened it's numerous it's happened a
few it's happened a few times um and
people have different like Nick's a
great guy he's a gentleman always always
cool and you know we had conversations
before and after and um you know I just
always thought it was going to be a tall
order to go up against big big as a you
know in LA and B Nick Cannon who's
obviously got a million other things on
your plate yeah and you're not going to
be able to give the full bandwidth to
the show that it probably would need you
know if you had a chance yeah
um Nick is just so talented man it's
crazy but you know it it they went on it
um it did what it did but you know again
it was hard to encroach into big space I
like what he's doing now on amp
um
what was the biggest record you were
just wrong about that you would you just
didn't like it or you didn't you didn't
think it was a hit but it ended up being
crazy biggest record I was wrong about
I don't miss too many records honestly
really I know
now it's as as time has gone on I really
rely a lot upon AO and amen you were
very good at that because I do because
we talked about the random white dudes
running rhythmic stations yeah and they
don't have
yeah
they just read the chart yeah and they
don't have like a brain around them like
hey like and the other thing I'll say
about you Doc is I always tell everybody
this when they ask about you I'm like
man Doc is if a mixtape comes out album
comes out the night it's out he'll text
me
yo what do you think about track nine I
think nine is the best one or you know
whatever and I don't that's not
it's your job but I just don't think a
lot of program directors that's my job
and my guys my team like Ayo who is in
Miami now it'll be nine o'clock here and
I'm listening to the music and he's in
Miami it's 12 o'clock he's listening to
the music and amen is in the bay and
we're sending each other notes about
what song we want you to play yeah at
seven o'clock at night like we're
passionate about yeah it'd be like if a
Drake album gets like I think the last
time a surprise Drake album dropped yeah
we're all on group chat like which one
which one what's the what's the signal
yeah yeah so no I mean I I like to I
like to stay tapped in um
man that's a that's a good question like
I've been in I've been doing it so long
like usually when I hear the hits I hear
the hits
um not too many that I've I've missed
um
I feel like nowadays I feel like there's
more and more songs that I'll hear
and I'll be like
because I you know Tick Tock is such a
weird tool yeah
and you know nowadays we have a lot of
song like like there's songs throughout
the years are just recently where
there's just been no hook you'll be like
yeah where's the hook it didn't matter
yeah those are hard records to um to
pinpoint yeah but you did say something
earlier when you mentioned um you
mentioned fetty WAP I remember having
some conversations with Leora around
that time because
we're a format like any other brand like
you need stars like and you and and I
thought he was a star he was a star and
I thought the first album was amazing
2014 2015 when he went on tour with
Chris Brown as many people showed up to
see him the album was crazy and then as
they started moving on to the next
project I honestly thought that there
were still better songs on the first
project I remember
um you know getting a record and
listening to it and lior and I got into
kind of a heated discussion was that the
song with no hook
yeah I think it was about school or
something like that but there was a song
that you and I listened to in the office
and there was no hook it was like he was
trying to do a Dreams and Nightmares
thing it was something different yeah I
remember really all like you know you
got to give an artist you know a chance
to grow with it I'm like yeah but it's
gotta be a hit yeah and like he needs a
hit like we I need him I need I need him
because he was the face of our format in
some respects for that year and now you
look up and it's 2023 and it's
it's he's about to go get lost gone you
know and it's just like the NBA you
gotta have a face you have to have faces
right now you know it's it's it's Drake
it's
um you know the weekend it's it's
Kendrick it's Rihanna
um cardi cardi
um you want you want we need more of the
faces like we can't look up five years
from now and it's still those guys you
know we gotta have some more faces just
like the NBA needs new faces when LeBron
and Seth go away I mean it's important
so you have a great relationship with uh
the guys at uh XO and the weekend yeah
what is it like hanging out with
somebody who is so
you know to the fans kind of mysterious
and not out there like the weekend is
somebody who if you're around them he's
just a normal guy but like he's
definitely not that if you just consume
his content he's a very mysterious guy
and I think he's probably gonna get out
of that soon with the show coming out
and all that he's a really nice dude man
yeah like
just really impressed with his character
as I am with J Cole like character man
like as famous as they are you kind of
like watch them from a from afar and
you're like you know it's a good dude
man you know um gives people their
attention you can only imagine that he's
getting pulled in several directions
I've seen able at
you know family functions you know with
the EXO team like wow he's here and he's
engaged it's not I mean I mean engaged
in terms of he's engaging in
conversation he's not on his phone right
you know saying I'll look up and he's
playing with my son and I mean that to
me is what really sets them apart like
they're just good human beings man I
enjoy being in the company 100
um
the one thing I want to kind of
breakdown is the science on why the
number one complaint I've been getting
from listeners and you've been getting
from listeners your whole your whole
career why is it every time I hear the
[__] radio it's the same [__] 10
songs now there is a science to this but
that's that I'm sure that that's been
the feedback for however many years you
guys play the same [__] you guys play
the same [__] yeah break down from Doc
winner the science of why a radio
playlist is very tight and why you might
hear five or six songs over and over
again if you listen all day driving an
Uber or something I like to use the
analogy of a nightclub
um our job is to retain listeners right
let's say if you were in a nightclub and
the DJ decided he wanted to go off on a
rant and play you know 30 minutes of
Frank Sinatra or whatever clear the
Dance Floor to the dance floor they
probably stay and wait until he got came
back to his senses doesn't happen in
radio they go find the other
they go they may not come back I've
actually been in a car and and not in
the case of uh of playing bad music but
a very long commercial break and saw
this Uber driver listening to us
you know go to the competition
obviously he was preferred us come back
we were still playing commercials and I
could see his anger
I'm gonna go back there instead because
you know and what retains them is a
record that they like that they can sing
not necessarily something they've never
heard you know right I think so I always
tell people it's like the average radio
listeners how how many minutes a day
might be 10 15 minutes so if you think
about it in that through that lens we
have we talked about PPM the meters are
like people get paid to wear these
little pagers and it tracks their
real-time listening so it's like you're
hoping to play something to keep
somebody around in that 10 minute window
that they happen to listen yeah so the
research and data on how you come up
with what the five powers are what all
goes into that
probably the most important thing is who
you're going to ask
you know do you like this record you
know who's your screen is what they call
you know it might be
18 to 34 year old women it could be 18
or 34 year old men it could be 18 or 34
year old
black women 18 to 34 year old Latino
women and as a programmer you got to
know what you're trying to you know what
moves the needle in your market for your
demo you know 18 to 34 Latino females
who listen to radio three hours you can
get that granular with it
um
and then you begin to understand you
know what moves the needle from for them
the more you listen to
um more you do research and the more you
ask the right questions you get a sense
of okay like this is what moves the
needle for them and then you you give
people what they want to keep coming
back you ever go to a restaurant and all
of a sudden they tell you oh we stopped
making your favorite meal I just had
just happened to me making my favorite
meal wow yeah we got bored with it just
happened come on man
yeah so
um I mean that's the science and again
it can be frustrating for people but you
know and there's a bunch of factors
right you'll have like call out which is
where you're pretty much kind of is that
a how would you describe call out for a
radio station you call out to people
that fit the screen and you play hooks
of songs you can ask what do you think
of this song what do you think of this
song yeah you'll see streaming data for
the market yep you check Shazam
so uh and then there's also the M scores
which is is that something you guys you
obviously M scores is like I look at it
but you know somebody could have turned
the song off you don't really know what
the reason is and that's what the
switching score is someone turned off
the song or a number of people turned
off the song
while it was playing
um and sometimes you can look at the
song and say okay you see other factors
that contribute to you know might be the
wrong time of day you play the song it
might just be tired of it right or rest
it and then test it again is what we
like to sing but where do you see uh not
only just obviously radio but just music
going in the next five years or so doc
because it's it's I mean it's forever
evolving everything is changing we've
been talking about this r b thing uh for
the last two or three years it's coming
back coming back I know we're we're
getting a lot of um r b records that are
that our audience is really enjoying
here in La
um there's Latin trap that I think is
making it has been around for a number
of years that it's making a compelling
case to be a part of our Arsenal on the
radio
um man we just we're looking for hits
man I mean you talk to a lot of people
right now they think that this is
amongst the worst cycles that we've in a
long time in terms of people making
records records yeah it's I feel like
most of the female artists are the ones
who are providing
like real records like I'm thinking even
it's like you know like you know I don't
know what it is about that either
because like
I think times are different when you
think about curating artists back in the
90s it was pre-streaming and so if you
decided to take the sleep of faith and
someone thought that you were you know
you had the talent you went for it you
know because
going for it means you were going to
sell a lot of Records you're going to go
on tour and you're going to make a lot
of money now here's the streaming thing
I just keep throwing shots you just keep
throwing shots out and you can make a
lot of money and
yeah what's my what's my incentive to
make uh
would be great when I can take care of
my family because I'm making money you
know putting out a lot of music
unfortunately you've obviously had to
fire a lot of people in your career
I've had to part ways with people I like
to put it that way what is the craziest
reason you've had to part ways with an
employee
without saying who they are obviously
wow
I've had a couple of uh hygiene issues
really yeah
so someone's staying they were they
smell bad yeah what's that conversation
like
[Laughter]
I think that brother was just in um
and I have to think about it that that
brother at that time he was just I think
he got in the divorce and he was just
having a rough time yeah he got divorced
and he was living in a hotel and you
know but it was it was making the
working experience unbearable because he
he didn't uh he wasn't showering man
well I saw him damn fad I've had some
I've had so many crazy experiences that
just beyond
um and one of the craziest was um I'm in
Jacksonville
anybody of mine I had a friend that
listened to the radio station and he she
wanted to meet with me about
uh some type of charity event that the
radio station was going to support and
at the time I was doing afternoons in
Jacksonville slow jam show in St Louis
and I was overseeing
whatever urbans we had at the time I
think it might have been five or right
before I got to the 80 that I'd do now
but it was like five or so and I
remember her coming in my office I'm in
the office and I'm kind of like not
really paying attention I guess sounds
like a great idea why don't you leave
something with my assistant and then um
she said okay and one other thing and
she gets up and she locks my door
and she starts to disrobe and I just
remember saying yo what are you doing
and my face and my eyes lock with her
eyes and she like and she realized that
and then she just started crying and so
I I you know I sat her down in my chair
and I was like yo like like what are you
doing like was this like your plan like
this was your this was your day you
thought this did you think this through
at all like I just you know and I was
like yo I'm flattered but like it's this
is not going down like this manline I
feel bad that you feel like you want to
sit here and compose yourself because
right now I'm starting to think like
okay so what can happen right now yeah
you're crying crying woman in my office
you know and so I went and got my
assistant you know gave her some tissue
told her to sit here for a while you
know when you're ready to go go I gotta
go do my show but you know like that's
crazy it was it was it was kind of nice
have you ever had someone in your
Jacksonville days fly to Jacksonville to
see you face to face to be like yo what
the [__] why is the song not getting
played I feel like I listen I don't want
to keep saying I feel like Diddy's the
kind of guy who might like just show up
to the office one day I could be wrong
no no uh he's he's not he's not that
kind of guy like he's not like I mean
he'll he'll text me about a record right
but you know again I I think I don't
really I don't emote that so I don't
really get that back that's good yeah
I'm not gonna say something crazy to
Diddy he's not gonna say something crazy
to me and every once in a while when I
when I do get that kind of response I'm
I'm not that guy I'm just like okay cool
I'm out you um
we did real Street Fest in
2019 or 18. what year did we do Street
Festival we did it in 19 yeah pandemic
was in 20. yeah yeah we had a great
great time I know we always talk about
you and I like
the radio Show's kind of dying like
obviously I heart has the Jingle Ball
tour they have all these things that are
very like top 40 friendly even there you
know um shout out to the I Heart
Festival that we do in Vegas every year
um
do you are you do you can you foresee or
I know it's something that you want to
do but an urban hip-hop version
nationally of some sort of
show or Festival
I mean I hope so I thought about it for
years but you know every year something
some Dynamic changes right you know went
from the radio show to us realizing we
need to do festivals and we put together
this great event it was amazing and then
the pandemic happened and the pandemic
kicks in and then you know now you're in
the middle of a financial crisis and you
know it's hard for you to go to your
company and say hey give me these
millions of dollars to throw an event to
throw at an event that may not make the
money back and so
you um instead you you know you start
Partnerships with people who do that for
a living and say Hey you know how can we
do this together do this together how
give me a bunch of tickets to give away
yeah you know kind of what happened with
Dre in the Super Bowl Dr Dre which was
crazy you know big you know big have a
great relationship gave us
tickets to sit in his suite in the Super
Bowl for us to give away you know and
then obviously the Drake tours come in
for remember uh some of these Mega
festivals yeah the Kanye and Drake show
that we gave away
um right before yeah yeah
um did you go to that oh yeah I was in
uh Dr with my wife for our anniversary
yeah watch it on Amazon
it was not experience it was legendary
uh do you see yourself
ever leaving radio
uh I mean yeah I mean I've been doing it
for
34 years is my anniversary in January
so at some point because I could see at
some point you know Apple coming and
being like hey Doc
I mean I I get I get approached to be on
boards right now
um which are of interest to me wow
because you get an opportunity to play
in a different Pond that you don't
normally play with but also you know use
the relationships you've established
over Years to you know to to make some
Headway so I mean I don't know man I
mean I I try to stay in shape and and I
yeah you are the definition of black
don't cry I try to stay in shape and and
uh I got a I got a young son who's yeah
he's young and he's hooping he's a
hockey player oh he's playing hockey the
black hockey player hey there's a few of
those and he's four you know what I'm
saying so you know I want to spend more
time with him yeah you were on you
called and yelled at us while your wife
is in labor oh man that was the craziest
thing ever I don't know why why I
answered the phone there was that you
guys kept calling we did the celebrity
smash thing I was like I'd be damned if
we let this [__] fly over these Airways
before we get the green light with Doc
winner so I'm in the hospital holding
one of my wife's legs as my son is
coming out and the nurse is holding the
other leg and he's got you know my phone
I'm just like yo oh why did it's got to
be an emergency while you guys keep
calling so I answered the phone and the
nurse looks at me like are you [__]
kidding me right now and your wife's
screaming in the background yes and me
and head for sure assumed you guys were
having sex so I was like yo doc just
answered the phone while he's piping his
lady and then we realized oh they were
there was a baby
my son's my son's Crown was out at the
time you guys are calling I was like my
wife's like yo you answer the phone
while my son is coming out of me I was
like yo it's important
um before you go what are your top five
favorite albums of all time off the top
of your head without thinking about top
five favorite albums
um in music in music you I'll I'll give
you the you don't have to say hip-hop
um definitely
um Laura Miss educational Lauryn Hill
okay it was groundbreaking
uh Keith sweat's first album Make It
Last Forever okay
um
Notorious B.I.G which one ready to die
or life after death ready to die okay
um damn I actually posted these one time
on my um on my Instagram
oh attack who was the other one it was
the album and when I talk about an album
I mean I'm just playing every track on
the app course because it's that good
and I've been around for a long time so
um it's hard to lock down five
um
I do remember uh
Jay's first album Reasonable Doubt
Reasonable Doubt was incredible
incredible I remember Tiffany green
saying there's this guy from New York
he's going to be the greatest rapper
ever
and I was like
really it's a big thing to say you know
she's like no he's a guy
and um
like she was right she was right
um and uh
[Music]
oh no man anything more recently that
you just can can remember just liking
like yo this is just the body of work
that
I would be remiss if I didn't say I just
think the Drake is remarkable man just
and it's it's an interesting
conversation because you know we're
about to celebrate the 50th anniversary
of hip-hop yep I happen to be around New
York City at the time when it was
bubbling up in most instances New
Yorkers claim you know we've claimed
everything the best basketball you could
claim hip-hop and to be faculty blame
hip-hop and factual I remember playing
ball and thinking that we were the only
guys that could do it and come into
Vegas and playing in a um in a an
attorney yeah like pizza basketball
those are all debatable hip-hop there's
no debate you're playing against Byron
Scott and like yo we went back home like
yo these dudes from L.A can play ball
you know um
but so the purest will definitely find
it difficult to accept the fact that a
dude from
from Canada might be
to go to go yeah um but when you think
about body of work as long as I've been
in this business to have a body of work
from a radio perspective where we
research music yeah from our perspective
from the radio side there's nobody who's
ever been close it's it's the most
insane thing that you've ever seen like
he's the most prolific hit maker we've
ever seen it's literally
even when you sort the list by artists
it's just literally his songs and his
name and then the score on the right is
is through the roof and you're just like
I've never seen anybody do anything like
that who's the who's second in that list
because if you were to pull up like
titles in the library
who would be the second person is it
like Wayne is it deep pain I mean I
don't know you know like
man there's not a lot of people that
have nobody has the Drake list
you might you might maybe maybe Wayne
that's a good it's a really good
question maybe it's Wayne but it's not
only that the list is long it's just the
the quality the research the quality
it's the research like you could you
could he might be able to do a show with
these 20 songs this night and another 20
songs another you could do a show with
all the features another yeah like who
could do that I'll give you that nobody
could do that but but again I honestly
remember when I put real on in LA
there's an artist who again I won't name
but he told me like you know they don't
they don't like his music here and I was
just like huh you know no like this West
Coast we don't like that I'm like dude
like you're really wrong there's not a
place where people don't like Drake's
music yeah yeah like this guy can sell
out uh you know crypto for four or five
nights like they like him yeah for you
coming to La be I was on the radio when
Dan dropped and there was just that
moment when Kendrick dropped damn those
songs would not go away yeah like love
and obviously hump but there was just
songs that were in power rotation for
like two years that's a great album it
was just wild to like I just remember
being like [__] man like I love this
album I [__] hate it because all I do
is play these [__] songs all day I
love the fact because that it was at a
time when you just put a station on in
LA and it was a guy from L.A a brother
that you know who had a management team
around him that were brothers and so I
mean it was just perfect timing for us a
lot of a lot of things like that fell
into our lab you remember our first show
in La that we did real show 25 15 we had
Kendrick was the headline and we had
future uh he and Drake had just done a
show and we get a call Sunday morning
never felt anything like that in an
arena in my life when he stepped out on
that stage I actually have a picture in
my office yeah yeah you got it the
craziest momentum I've ever seen and I
was like man like we gonna be here I
didn't think to like I think the first
real show I might have been a part of
was J Cole headlining and cardi B was
yeah yeah was on the show but this was
PRI this was like I mean cardi had
records but it wasn't like first album
way way early yeah yeah I don't even
know if the first album was out very
long no it hadn't been that long no yeah
she only had one album right yeah but I
remember being in the dressing room and
like uh seeing them to talk yeah yep yep
and I think he was giving her some yeah
I've seen a couple of those if you
remember real Street Fest
um whatchamacallit was on our show uh
Dojo yeah I interviewed her uh yeah
she's it's crazy I always tell the
homies at RCA I'm like you guys [__]
job so easy if you work at Republic RCA
good [__] luck you don't have to work
in records much hey I have a new Drake
song it's added I have a new weekend
song it's added hey man well we added
Dojo to that show let's say our show was
in August and we added her like maybe in
May she she was not she was not the same
person
uh by the time the tiger remix wasn't
out yet by the time by the next year
is gone it went from who is this person
to
yeah man those those are the stories
that that I love because you gotta think
that radio has something to do with that
oh 100 100 well look doc I appreciate
you
um you guys can go follow doc if you
want to follow him he does not you're
not like a big social media guy no
really not winter it's like winners
um
anything uh else on the way signing on
more radio stations obviously you know
you you and I know that I heart's kind
of going through the financial [__]
right now but like you've weathered a
million storms in that in that sense but
like anything coming that you're excited
about are you just
um cultivating or living black
um this year that'll be in August okay
and basically paying homage to uh
hip-hop's 50th Anniversary like dude I
was I was back there in the 70s like
right couldn't tell me as amazing as it
was that it would be he's celebrating
this thing 50 years later and it would
mean what it meant to our community
again people like Gabe Brothers they're
brothers that are millionaires a number
of them from it it's it's amazing did
you ever have any big ear Tupac moments
Tupac interview Tupac um in LA
uh after
um Jason's Lyric is or poetic justice
poetic justice poetic justice movie was
um he clearly had been out the night
before still smelled like alcohol
um but he was so well spoken
and then uh after the interview I
remember I was flying back to
St Louis and my lady who was my first
wife was sitting in the lobby reading a
book and he saw her and he took off
running towards her and his boy like
tackled him and pulled him to the side
and he started laughing and she was
oblivious to it I always remember was
like damn what would happen if he had
gotten to her like it was gonna be a
problem she might have been your former
wife a lot earlier could have been could
have been could have been but nah man so
thank you for doing this of course doc
appreciate you man
hey we gotta wrap up an interview
brought to you by hardean Las Vegas
appreciate y'all watching hey don't
forget when you go to Vegas you got to
go to Hardee man it's the craziest
dispensary you'll ever walk into it
smells like [__] heaven in there all
right get in that Uber when you hit Sin
City tell them take me to Jardine
they're gonna take you you're gonna get
a wild selection of the just top top of
the line cannabis the best selection
you'll go uh be able to see in the US
Plus on top of that they got the crazy
gear they got the clothes they got the
bikinis they got a wonderful selection
of Bud tenders that are very good at
their job man they'll take care of you
tell them that bootleg have sent you the
bud tenders are Harding don't know what
that means they're gonna get you hooked
up right all right go follow them online
Harding underscore Las Vegas or just go
check out their website too man
hardinglasvegas.com and when you're in
Vegas pull up to Jardin or you're
playing yourself for real